сподіваюся савченко на відблиски імунітет не
кв язичний так і дипломатичний він вона
вище народний депутат до України
алай дав агатка у парламентській
асамблеї раді європі за законом на дату
rca нести і посу гарантовано а
лавру силу так їхній випад як
міжнародне право схожий знайди і я
хочу я хоче і значить ще у рішення суду
адже суті на спроба контр-аргумент
уват інакше до кози станові статусу
Яга-то парламентської асамблеї рада і
ворога парламентської асамблеї ради
Європи і від нас льодок
української льотчиці винних та на зустріч
в ізоляторі та краї на члена радою Європи
для євросоюзу з вуха вали ігнор у вані та
зубів я за ніки росія взяла на себе
підписали протокол про імунітет
комори в парі
просто ціни porsche міжнародно забув я
за неї кіно їх і кремль
адже з і треба мінський протокол
савченко малий звивини та точки vr з ними
нового руку верховний представник єс та
за зовнішню це вас піковою політикою
складу я свою дипломатично збрую вашу
черву я хочу вас запам'ятають та ми є Петро та
мого контакту з адвокатом і наші
представлені клином оголитися брат і
участь у судовому процесі
ціни просто алому над син праці йому і
читку з youtube йому ситуацію ле дезір
вище праві потік савченко алое і проїж
їх на законі пов'язаних у Росії ми душі
риб таємницю свіжому за їх і частка ми
ручка і жити, а свобода верховенства
права сабо залежності Європи ж того
наскільки ефективно можливих за
гастрит та закласти малюка частка надій
савченко та інших планерних росіян
українців у Європі побоїться у витрачає і
україну я все буде рачина
євромайдану
ідея свободи верховенства права
справедливості
від же сама про ch лося таддеї по суті ми
в витрати але часто ну Європи теж тільки
десятки депутатів європарламенту ви
вирішила почати з клав широкої показати і
а не про gunvor з кремлем дадуть
результат у нього волосся лавандування
що дня один з та начебто плутати та вікі
програлася до акту
нам жива або також відсилаючи lastapp
услу Росії про євросоюзі смагляву нягань
дзвенить і українську льотчицю